between white witchcraft and black
witchcraft the white witchcraft is
supposed to be the more benign there
different types of Witchcraft and
there's green black red so the why
witchcraft just to explain super quick
so witchcraft in general is control and
manipulation is something that you do to
get something in in return so why
witchcraft is the type of Witchcraft
that people use to connect with Nate is
they don't use that to Herm they think
that they are doing things for good they
are doing that type of witchcraft help
people super connected with nature with
the animals to that that type of worship
then you have the green witchcraft which
is the type of witches that use um a lot
of nature a lot of herbs kind of like
remedies things like that so you if you
are a wi you can be moving in in in a
lot of different things and then the the
black one is actually the one that's
used to harm people is the one that you
use to to control to kill to put to put
courses